[Music]
a whispering batman inspired by kirk
cobain in slippers robert pattinson had
some wild ideas about how to bring
batman to life find it all right here
the batman is finally out in theaters
and there is no one better to play the
eccentric billionaire bruce wayne than
robert pattinson his version of batman
is less polished and grungier than
previous iterations and the actor has
found ways to make the role his own he
even tried to change a well-known
hallmark attributed to the franchise
batman's voice in order to disguise
himself from his alter ego bruce batman
films have always included some
alteration to the character's voice be
it christian bale's trademark gritty
roar or ben affleck's voice modulator in
the dceu films changing the voice is an
important aspect of the role not to be
outdone pattinson tried to put his own
flair on the concept though it didn't
last for very long in an attempt to
distinguish himself from his
predecessors pattinson wanted to steer
away from what audiences had come to
know as batman and do something
radically different in an interview with
jimmy kimmel live he explained how he
tried to change the voice
i just thought because everyone does
this kind of gruff gravely thing i'm
like i'm going to do the opposite as for
what pattinson decided his take was
going to be he told kimmel i'm going to
go really
whispery and i tried to do it for the
first like two weeks
and it just looked absolutely atrocious
the actor took his shot and although it
didn't immediately hit with the
production of the batman he eventually
found his stride after his first attempt
at a different voice he found a happy
medium pattinson admitted that something
seemingly happens when you put on the
suit after he found his groove he was
able to find the best voice for the film
inventions to robert pattinson's credit
what he was trying wasn't that far off
the mark with so many versions of batman
it's only natural that an actor may want
to try something new and he wasn't even
the first batman to try it when
initially trying on the costume
pattinson learned that batman veteran
christian bale had also tried to use a
similar intonation for batman begins
bale of course played an entirely
different batman where pattinson's
batman is reclusive and moody bale
emphasized bruce wayne's wealth and
privilege but even with this dichotomy
it seems that pattinson's instincts
weren't so different from bales bale has
been somewhat infamous for how dark and
rough his voice became when portraying
the batman persona though he has gotten
flack for the voice he puts on some fans
argue that it's important to
differentiate bruce wayne from batman
wayne is a recognizable figure in gotham
a local celebrity so he would need a
severe vocal change in order to protect
his identity pattinson felt comforted
that not only did bale try to do a
different voice but you can hear it in a
very early teaser trailer for the 2005
film you can also hear bale's early
voice experiment in his audition video
gotham needs you
and you serve gotham i serve justice
the voice isn't the only difference
between bale and pattinson's batman
director matt reeves has been very open
about his influences on the batman in an
interview for empire the director spoke
about how one of his main influences was
kurt cobain nirvana's something in the
way is featured heavily in the trailer
and there is a grungier aesthetic
present in the promotional materials at
first pattinson didn't agree saying
really that's kind of the opposite of
what my imagine bruce wayne to be but
eventually he started brainstorming on
the subject after his idea of the
whispering voice failed he had some
additional input pattinson joked to
jimmy kimmel that in the first costume
meeting i wanted to go like really
really really coco bane and kind of
wanted to wear like a dressing gown and
kind of fluffy like bugs bunny slippers
but the idea of grunge is still present
in this iteration of the batman even
without any whispering or flannel the
gritty aspect of the film is present in
batman's muscle car and beat up costume
and if their reactions to the batman
from fans and critics are any indication
pattinson certainly stuck the landing
despite his early vocal experiments
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you